we are now in a world where according to
our president Canadian Steel is a
national security threat to the United
States and Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau is a bad guy but brutal
North Korean dictator Kim jong-un is
funny smart a great negotiator has a
great personality and is loved by the
North Korean people that that's
according to president Donald Trump
interestingly two polls both done by
Ipsos one for global news in Canada and
one for Reuters in the United States
both of these new polls show that it's
not just Canadians but also Americans
that are more likely to agree with
Justin Trudeau on this issue of Canada
versus US trade then with Donald Trump
seventy-two percent of Canadians and I
guess somewhat surprisingly but in a
sense not that surprisingly 57 percent
of Americans approve of how Canada and
Justin Trudeau are handling the trade
dispute over the number who support
Donald Trump as the guy who's handling
it well check out these results for
questions were asked first of all do you
approve of how Trudeau is handling the
situation 57% of Americans agree 72% of
Canadians agree question number two the
situation has damaged relations between
the u.s. and Canada almost everybody
agrees on that 71% of Americans and 81
percent of Canadians third question was
Canada shouldn't overreact or statement
Canada shouldn't overreact to president
Trump's recent comments it was just
political posturing related to the NAFTA
negotiations again between 52 and 57
percent between Americans and Canadians
agree with that which is which basically
means half of both Americans and
Canadians to a degree think that this is
just a stunt from Donald Trump and
lastly I approve of how President Donald
Trump is handling the situation only 14
percent of Canadians agree with that but
interestingly only 37% of Americans even
agree with that what what horrible
anti-american Americans
or maybe they just understand that this
is a trade war that like many is one you
can't win you have to pick your battles
with whoever it is that you're working
with geopolitically and that may be
picking battles with allies and praising
brutal dictators is bad politics and
when you take sort of a step back from
it it's not really that surprising right
I mean just we've had this hyper
normalization which as I've spoken about
has kind of desensitized us to a lot of
the absurdity that that we're seeing but
it doesn't mean that some basic truths
don't remain self-evident right for
example Canada is a longtime ally of the
United States and Russia as of late is
not North Korea as of late for many many
decades is not and that doesn't mean
that I is a progressive and being
unfairly hostile or want to be unfairly
punitive to Russia or North Korea this
has become very popular among again it's
this sort of Leninist Hugo Chavez loving
Bashar al-assad defending Putin
defending strain of the left that strain
of the left is attacking other
progressives and saying you guys are
hypocrites you claim that you don't want
war yet you sound like you're pushing
for war with North Korea or with Russia
or with Syria or whoever that's not what
we're doing what I'm pointing out is
that we have to realize that hey wait a
second we're not alone on this planet
Canada has been an ally North Korea and
Russia have not and thus it's perfectly
rational and reasonable to the extent
that anybody in the White House's or is
a rational actor to deal with Canada as
an ally and not to deal with Kim jong-un
as this brilliant and incredibly
humorous a guy with an amazing
personality who can be trusted so that
that's the point that I'm making and I
actually read online in some
bottom-dwelling right-wing forum a
comment that was something like I'm glad
Trump is finally sticking it to Canada
and I thought sticking it to Canada for
what right providing steel for our tanks
what what exactly are we trying to stick
it to Canada
for and as usual the theme is one that
has continues to be persistent in the
Trump White House which is that Trump is
very sort of impressed with and taken by
authoritarian leaders and very eager to
go to negotiate with them and Canada is
not an authoritarian country it's a
quiet liberal democracy Justin Trudeau
not a megalomaniac authoritarian but
bilingual educated French Canadian it's
just not really appealing to Trump right
nothing about that impresses Trump and
in the end when it comes to the
specifics of the tariffs remember that
Donald Trump has identified what he's
calling unfair tariffs from Canada a lot
of those are retaliatory tariffs that
exist only because of either American
tariffs or American subsidies Dairy is
one example right the United States
dairy industry receives massive
subsidies without a Canadian tariff
because we have trade Andheri between
the u.s. and Canada if Canada didn't
react to the massive American subsidy on
dairy with the tariffs that they have
Canada's dairy industry would be
destroyed because shocker you don't
actually have dairy operating in a free
market because of those massive US
subsidies on the on the dairy industry
so it's all backwards and I
unfortunately see no way of getting out
of this bizarre sort of circular hell
that we're in other than voting in
November and voting again in 2010 and
I'm gonna actually talk specifically
about voting a little bit later on in
today's program